mcdonald's se retirer entièrement de
russie le géant américain va vendre
toutes ses activités dans le pays une
question de respect de ses valeurs selon
son pdg l'enseigné présente en russie
depuis plus de 30 ans avec 850
restaurant et 62 mille salariés le pdg
affirme que la chaîne de restauration
rapide engagée envers sa communauté
mondiale doit rester inflexible quant à
ses valeurs même chose pour le groupe
renault qui a vendu chayer ses actifs à
l'état russe le français est notamment
actionnaire du constructeur qui fabrique
les célèbres voitures lada on ignore le
montant de la transaction mais la perte
sèche pour renault et de plus de 2
milliards d'euros une addition
douloureuse en ce qui concerne
l'élargissement de l'alliance grâce à
l'intérêt de nouveaux membres à la
finlande et la suède je voudrais vous
informer que la russie n'a pas de
problème avec ces états et puis comment
va réagir moscou à l'adhésion de la
finlande à l'otan la russie va partager
potentiellement 1300 km de frontières
avec un nombre de lots tendent mais
l'élargissement de la structure
militaire de l'otan sur ces insultes à
tort de ces pays provoquera notre
réponse qui essaiera en fonction des
menace représentait donc de fait on près
des problèmes sans raison on est presque
sûr encore une fois 90% et bien parce
que c'était les vitres à l'arrière elles
sont un peu teinté mais c'est en tout
cas ça ressemblait à la voiture d
elisabeth bourdin en effet boeuf au delà
de deux de ces spéculations encore une
fois on vit quand même dans un climat
qui est absolument écoeurantes est en
marche a installé cette espèce de
situation dans laquelle on va débaucher
des personnes à droite à gauche est-ce
que ça doit être une femme
ça va être une femme apparemment ça va
être une femme mais bon vous savez bien
vous l'avait annoncé sur surtout
l'étonnant n'a rien n'assure du tout en
écrasant vos vêtements nommé madame
elisabeth board première ministre et l'a
chargé de former un gouvernement une
femme à matignon on attendait savent en
tout cas beaucoup attendait ça depuis
maintenant 31 ans madame
la première ministre c'est réalisable
comment expliquez-vous qu'il a fallu
attendre 30 explique puisque la france
est un pays particulièrement arriérés
papa la population française la classe
politique pour voir comment les femmes
sont traitées à l'assemblée nationale le
loup de se faire mouton le loup macron
il doit montrer patte blanche à la porte
de la bergerie il doit se mettre du miel
dans la voix pour dire regardez comme je
vais faire de l'écologie regardez comme
je vais faire du social mais en fait une
fois qu'il sera élu qu'il aura la
majorité à l'assemblée le louroux
deviendra un loup c'est une personne et
qui écoutait qui avec qui on pouvait
avoir des désaccords mais avec qui on
pouvait construire donc je pense qu'il a
un bilan et il est tout à fait
respectable on n'a pas été d'accord sur
certains points mais je crois pas qui je
crois qu'il a apaisé de certaine manière
dans un moment qui était assez compliqué
alors j'ai vu le déferlement de
contestation immédiat j'ai vu jean luc
mélenchon avec son arrogance habituelle
parler de sa prédécesseure alors qu'elle
vient juste d'être nommé c'est sûrement
une forme d'humour je veux dire matière
de machisme les deux truites qu'il a
fait mais celui qu'il fait aujourd'hui
sur elisabeth bord n'est pas mal c'est
donc en quelque sorte une nouvelle
saison de maltraitance sociale
écologique qui commence c'est un choix
un choix cohérent celui d'une premier
sera premier ministre antisocial qui va
se charger docilement de mettre en place
la feuille de route des manuels macron
je ne peux pas m'empêcher d'avoir une
pensée pour la première femme qui a
occupé ses fonctions
edith cresson je connais mal en born qui
est une personne remarquable qui a une
très grande expérience à la fois du
secteur public était préfète voudrais
dédier cette nomination à toutes les
petites filles en leur disant aller au
bout de vos rêves et rien ne doit
freiner le combat pour la place des
femmes dans notre société
en tout cas il est prêt à repartir dans
ces pyrénées pour s'occuper de ses
volets qui ne mérite un petit coup de
peinture voilà ce qu'il a confié dans
une interview donnée au parisien